okay let's talk about the real reason I
watched this show so broadchurch done
wrapped up seen it all all the series
one I I don't I'm certainly not gonna
rush out and see series two and three
not because first series of broadchurch
was bad but because I've now achieved my
actual goal in watching this which was
to try and get a better sense of Chris
Chibnall as a showrunner because he's
taking over Doctor Who which is my
favorite TV show and his Doctor Who and
his Torchwood output both of which he
worked on I didn't feel like they gave
me a very good sense especially cuz he
actually hasn't written anything for the
show in a while he hasn't written
anything since math Matt Smith's tenure
so I really wanted to try and get a
better sense of what he's good at so I
can try and figure out whether it makes
me feel better or worse now that he's
taking over Doctor Who and I I kind of
still don't know how I feel but I can I
can quantify why now before was just cuz
I lacked a point of reference I lacked
just an understanding of a recent show
that was completely his now I have that
I still don't know how that makes me
feel about him running Doctor Who here's
why this showed me there are definitely
things that he is good at as a writer he
is good at building believable
well-rounded characters he is good at
giving shades of gray
he is very good for the most part
episode five don't was handing and
giving us a serialized progression of a
story he's good at all that stuff the
problem is what he's good at is not what
I personally at least think Doctor Who
should be I mean the the the elephant in
the room is I don't think dr. who should
become a serialized story I just don't I
mean if you want to do stronger
connected tissue I think I mean there
are ways to do that I've talked about
that a little bit before I mean a really
good option would be a quest narrative
something like the key to time storyline
back in the
fourth doctor's era that that allows you
for to still have the doctor bouncing
around all these different settings
dealing with completely different sets
of characters every time but that each
time the doctor completes whatever the
whatever she's there to do for each one
it contributes to a greater cause a
greater mission like that degree of
civilization which isn't even really
serialization it's just the connective
tissue between stories as opposed to the
mystery boxes which is what we've
usually gotten I'm all in favor of
something like that but a truly
serialized sita's story something that
you don't you it's not finished it's not
finished until you watch the entire
thing I don't I don't want Doctor Who to
be that I love coming in and getting
usually a pretty complete and ideally
satisfying viewing experience every
single episode and knowing that
especially now knowing that it's going
to be ten episodes instead of thirteen
and they're gonna be a little bit longer
I really makes me nervous and I again
even when I look at the other things
that broad sure showed me that Jenelle
is good at in terms of developing
characters over time I don't want the
doctor to be stuck with a supporting
cast
you know episode after episode as they
get built and delved into so I mean I
there's the Companions obviously and
maybe this explains why we've got three
of them which I've said before seems
like a lot to me I know I and I know the
show was done three companions before
but it always feels like overcrowding to
me but maybe that's why he's done that
so that he has more recurring characters
to work through and I'm hoping it's not
an indication that he's going to try and
build some kind of additional supporting
cast that we keep seeing over and over
and over and over again
I like recurring characters but one
thing I never want Doctor Who to do is
to feel tied down I don't want it I
don't what I love about the show
fundamentally if I truly break it down
is the fact that it can go anywhere any
when and be about almost anything I love
that freedom
so it's one of the reasons series 8
really annoyed me because no matter
where they went because Clara wasn't
staying in the TARDIS to keep traveling
the doctor had to keep coming back to
earth I kind of hated that tether and
that arguably it's been there with the
other companions before but it was
really emphasized with Clara that he had
to keep coming back here to pick her up
over and over and over again I don't
like it being a feeling restricted in
that way I wouldn't like it to feel
restricted narrative Lee which is what
to me at least a serialized story would
feel like it feels like you are
shrinking down and saying this is what
this series of Doctor Who will be it'll
just be this and there's also the
concern when you do a surreal life story
like if you don't nail it you don't get
a reprieve next episode when you when
the story shifts episode 2 episode
shifts tone shift setting shifts
supporting cast a one of a story not
working doesn't sink the ship because
you get something new next time when
it's just another piece of the same
continuing story the overall story has
to work and if it doesn't that's kind of
it and I guess I'm most nervous now
especially and again all this is
supposition we don't really know exactly
how Chris Chibnall is approaching him
what we know that he's done he's
engaging in a writers room style of
handling the new series which is new
because usually on Doctor Who was
written basically on assignment from the
showrunner it would the the episodes
would go out to various writers and they
just write it they didn't have a group
writers room for the actual process of
writing episodes he's bringing that in
which is kind of more in line certainly
with American television I don't know
how many British shows use the writers
room but he's doing that and like I said
we're getting more companions we're
getting sure we're getting a shorter
series with longer episodes and of
course now we have a woman doctor and I
really worry
that this is too much new stuff at once
and I don't mean that in like some sort
of superficial no one couldn't handle
this one change at once no of course we
can but what what it why it makes me
nervous is if any one of these new
changes doesn't work any one of them
this many companions this short a series
this method of writing and who knows
whatever else he plans to bring to the
table that's new and different if any of
these new things don't work there is a
depressingly large chunk of people who
are going to blame the fact that it's a
female doctor even if there ends up
being a problem that is not her that's
still gonna get blamed and i don't want
that to happen i want a female doctor to
get as fair shake as possible and i
really worry about all these other
changes he's planning to bring some of
them at least potentially not working
and then because we go well the
thirteenth doctor's run wasn't very good
is very easily transformed into the
thirteenth doctor wasn't very good so i
just i would i would really hate to see
that happen
and in some ways i'm and again
broadchurch was good and it does show me
that he can be a good showrunner but the
strengths that it showed me are now make
me more nervous about having him run
Doctor Who than I was before
which I didn't expect I thought if I was
gonna end up more nervous it was going
to be because broadchurch wasn't very
good but it was and yet here I am more
nervous than I was before just because
the way in which broadchurch was good is
so different from the way in which
Doctor Who is good when it is good or at
least to my preferences of what Doctor
Who is and maybe other folks really
would love a serialized approach and you
know what that's fine I can only speak
from my perspective but speaking of
someone who loves this show and loves
the general formatting and the freedom
that the general formatting has allowed
the show to have I look at what he's
already said he's gonna do and what
brunch or just show me Jim Nell is good
at and I were
a lot of really fundamental changes and
as far as I'm concerned I'm talking
about much bigger changes their female
doctor because at the end of the day I
don't think that is as fundamental to
change the show as some people think it
is but restructuring it just doing a
completely different narrative approach
that is a fundamental change and that
makes me nervous I'm not saying it can't
work it could anything can work any idea
that any showrunner filmmaker writer
whatever any idea can potentially work
it can also potentially go very very
wrong
and I'm not saying that it will but I'm
now I'm now just more nervous which not
ideal so those are my thoughts on that
that's how having finished broadchurch
my thoughts on Shivan all have adjusted
changed
I had possibly been made a little bit
worse dang it so Christian and end of
series 1 of budgets your overview
thoughts of the show as a whole how we
did or doesn't how it does or doesn't
impact your thoughts on how Chibnall may
or may not run Doctor Who whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
the stuff to do such as like subscribe
hit that notification bell because
people are saying I'm not showing up in
the subscription feed these days and you
consider supporting me on patreon and
follow me Twitter I do a podcast with my
partner Liz links for all that stuff is
down in the description plus some other
stuff as well
I have t-shirts so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]